Blair scored 144 points this football
season he scored all his points with
50-yard field goal that's actually
pretty impressive 50th that's like close
to record-breaking and even in the
National Football League I think the
records like 60 yards or something
so that's Blair seems like a fairly
impressive individual he scored all his
points with 50-yard field goal kicks
50-yard well 50-yard field goal kicks
I'm just underlying that because I'm
impressed by how far those field goals
are which are each worth three points so
a field goal and American football I
should clarify for those of you from
other countries who think we're talking
about soccer a field goal is worth three
points each he played he played in 16
games this season how many field goals
did Blair make in each game assume he
made the same number in each game so
this guy's incredibly is an incredibly
consistent field goal kicker he makes
50-yard field goals he makes the same in
every game so let's think about how many
field goals did he make in each game so
there's a couple of ways you can do this
we could first figure out well how many
field goals did he make in the season so
he scored 144 points he scored 144
points total and if we divide that by
three we divide that by the fact that a
field goal gets you three points per
field goal so the total number of points
divided by the points per field goal
this should give us the total number of
field goals he had so this right over
here is going to be equal to so three
goes into 144 let me do this on the side
right over here 3 goes into 144 3 goes
into doesn't go into 1 it goes into 14 4
times 4 times 3 is 12 subtract 14 minus
12 is to bring down a 4 3 goes into 24
perfectly it goes exactly 8 times 8
times 3 is 24 we have no remainder so
144 divided by 3 is equal to 48
so all season he's kicked 48 48 field
goals field
field goals now we still haven't
answered their question how many do you
make in each game and we're assuming
it's the same number in each game so
this is a total number across 16 games
to find out the average he makes in each
game we divide this by 16 so let's take
48 total field goals divided by 16 games
divided by 16 games is going to be well
48 divided by 16 is three this is equal
to three three field goals field goals
field goals per per game and we're done
how many field goals did he score it
make in each game he scored three